this is a production of Cornell
University
all right thank you for that
introduction and for the invitation to
come here I've already enjoyed meeting
everyone so far so before I get started
I'll actually do my acknowledgments
first mainly to point out so all of the
Miscanthus work that I'm going to show
Eric sacks has been the the PI leading
this project and it's been a huge
international effort so many many
collaborators around the world and
helped us get this done
all right so I'm going to spend the
first half of the talk discussing
Miscanthus and our breeding efforts and
the genetic diversity of Miscanthus and
then I'm going to get into a couple
bioinformatics topics
so both talking about poly rad for
genotype calling and talking about a new
method that I'm working on for sorting
out virologist low site and then when
you have an allele polyploid reference
genome right so Miscanthus if you're not
familiar with it is a it's a c4 grass
that's a perennial and it's native to
East Asia the very broad distribution in
East Asia this is a close relative of
sugar cane so that puts it within the
Andrew Gagne with neighs and sorghum as
well and so we're interested in it for
bioenergy because as a c4 grass it does
photosynthesis very efficiently right
but it's much more temperate adapted
than most c4 grasses so we can take
advantage of that you know c4
photosynthesis would have a longer
growing season than say maize we can
create triploids that are sterile and
that helps mitigate invasiveness
concerns in the US and it also has some
environmental benefits on being a
perennial is putting in a nice deep root
system that helps prevent soil erosion
and runoff from fertilizer especially
when this is interspersed in between our
annual cropping systems so we have a
couple different species shown here so
there's Miscanthus sacra Flores and
right under it sacra Flores otário'
right Arius which is a subspecies so
that's it's one of the parents of the
popular biomass clone giganteus which is
oops which is down here as well as
another species that's more clumping
which is sign ANSYS and its close
relative flora Julis and sign ants this
is also popular as an ornamental so
here's a tiny little ornamental variety
that this pretty but would be terrible
for biomass alright so I'm going to
refer to this commercial biomass clone
as 1993 1780 that's a
number in the hue botanical garden so
we've started calling it that we had
been calling it the Illinois clone but
it has nothing to do actually with
Illinois so that was a little bit too
self-centered of us so that this is a
one of these sterile triploid hybrids so
it's a hybrid between tetraploid sacra
florist and a diploid sign iNSYS and
this isn't something that was
intentionally bred it was collected in
1930 in the wild in Japan by a Danish
botanist brought to Europe from there
and then eventually North America I mean
so biomass uses of this include
combustion and a biomass boiler we're
actually heating one of our greenhouses
this way right now there's some research
into converting it into liquid fuels and
then it has other more generic biomass
uses like paper making or construction
or animal bedding now one big problem is
this is right this is one vegetatively
propagated clone so that makes it very
susceptible to if a new disease comes
along it could wipe out the entire
system for that and we're also wanting
to create some new biomass clones for
better environmental adaptation so this
is these these three maps what I'm
showing here they're all hardiness zone
maps of Japan and Europe and in the US
and so you know this is showing them the
minimum winter temperature that we
typically see and these are lined up by
latitude as well so right over here we
we've got a know the approximate
collection location of this clone and
you can see that it's in the cárdenas
zone 8 or 9 so that's about the type of
winter that it can survive and then if
you look up in Europe it's about the
same hardiness zone so it's able to deal
with the winters there as well
but because it's a more northern
latitude it's going to flower later
because the because the summer days are
longer right and that's good for for
pure biomass yield because as soon as
this plant flowers it's basic
stopped its vegetative growth for the
season so that enables it to continue
growing for longer up there as in some
areas it doesn't flower at all verses in
the US if you look at the same latitudes
we have much harsher winters right so if
we try growing it where we are in
Illinois if we have a particularly bad
winter especially with first year
plantings we got a lot of freeze damage
all right or you could bring it further
south where the winters are more mild
but then the summer days are too short
and it flowers too early to yield well
and because this is the only clone we
are getting into this danger zone where
like a farmer says oh I try it out
Miscanthus it didn't really work out for
me I guess I won't do that anymore but
Miscanthus itself is a genus is native
to a huge range of environments in East
Asia we have Miscanthus sacra forests
and hardiness zone 3 so very cold
regions in Russia and then we can also
go even a lot further south and where
this clone originated to get germ plasm
that will flower later so we really have
the ability to select genotypes that
will be much better for specific
environments in North America
and this is just an example so and at
the beginning of 2014 we had an
extremely cold day where I got down to
negative 25 Celsius so this is the
following spring and here in the lower
right this is that that commercial clone
having taken a lot of damage and these
are just some other clones that we had
that various people had made so just
just from a few different crosses we
have some that are better at dealing
with the winter all right so now I'll
talk a bit about Miscanthus Sciences so
this is one of the parents of that of
that clone this one is a exclusively
diploid very rarely will find in
triploids and in the wild but mostly
diploid so this is a clumping grass so
it will stay kind of together in one
clump and it doesn't really spread
unless you deliberately divided native
and its native range it grows on
hillsides and in grasslands and this is
this is the one that you'll popular
commonly see as an ornamental plant
around the US and in Europe as well so
we had a huge collection of Miscanthus
from our various collaborators and we
ran a rad C core genotyping by
sequencing on these to understand the
population structure so each of these
different colors represents an ancestral
population that we determined with the
structure software and each pie chart is
one individual shown where it was
collected so the takeaway from this is
we have these seven populations and we
can see how we relate they're related to
each other so we were able to see that
southeast China was sort of at the
center of diversity in the center of
radiation for the species and it
actually went directly from there to
Japan rather than than going through
mainland Asia first and which is
consistent with what we know about
warming after the last ice age right and
so
also have these planted and some field
trials actually these these have been
wrapped up these were planted in 2012
and so what was also so great about
having in these international
collaborations as we had a wide variety
of field sites so three in North America
and three and Asia now there are some
import restrictions into the US so the
two sites Colorado State and the
University of Illinois we had a much
smaller set of germ plasm but this n EF
new is new energy farms in Ontario so
they were able to plant the whole set as
well as a Hokkaido University Kangwon
National University and @jj University
this is a subtropical site where the
others were temperate so we got some to
see some interesting jiabaili effects
there right so one thing this was part
of Honshu Dongs PhD thesis was looking
at overwintering ability in these
populations and he could definitely see
there was this very clear relationship
with the latitude origin and how well
they overwintered at the northern sites
but there there are a few genotypes that
were from more southern latitudes that
still overwinter decently well so these
are good targets for breeding if we want
something that's high yielding from
being southern adapted but can still
survive our winters
right we also looked of course at
biomass yield of these so each each of
these box plots they're ordered by the
latitude of the field trial each one
represents a field trial and each box is
a different population and just due to
misidentification during collection we
had some diploid first-generation
hybrids between sign ANSYS and sacra
forests and those actually performed
fantastically well in our tamper at
sites so there's some sort of hybrid
vigor between sign ANSYS and sakura
forests and it's not pretty specific so
okay the dotted line is the triploid
commercial clone and some of the diploid
x' exceeded that and at j-jane
university or southern site we saw that
when we looked at the southern adapted
germ plasm it really did amazingly well
so like right here this is tick mark
indicating 80 tons per hectare now this
is extrapolated up from single plant lot
so the realistically it's probably
something smaller than that
but even if we're estimating it
conservatively this could compete with
sugarcane which would really be a
game-changer because even though we
might be able to grow sugar cane in this
region you don't have to replant
Miscanthus as often so this could
actually be be a better biomass crop
than sugarcane even where sugarcane is
popular of course we need to do more
studies to actually show that but this
is a very promising initial result right
because we had the collection locations
of everything and we had different field
trial locations we were also able to
build a climate model showing roughly
what would be the best place to go
collect for better germ plasm for these
sites so what went into this model was
the yield of each genotype at each site
as well as the bio climatic variables
like mean annual temperature temperature
of the coldest month precipitation
for each field trial location and each
collection location so southern Japan is
sort of it's like I don't want to say
common knowledge but I guess in this
campus community calling common
knowledge that oh southern Japan is
where you go for the best Miscanthus so
that did come up in our model for
temperate sites but we also found that
high elevation regions in China
especially at lower latitudes could also
be very high yielding and we have this
one particular genotype that sort of
exemplified that this one has done
really well in the field it's been a
good parent for breeding and that's
because it has the you know the cold
temperature from the high elevation but
it's flowering time is adapted to that
lower latitude so flowers later versus
if we looked at our subtropical location
in some ways it was the opposite in
terms of what did better so you know we
had our very high yielding types that
were from Southeast China but the model
predicts that if we go collect the root
riyuku Islands and Taiwan and the
Philippines we'll probably get some even
better Miscanthus and I'm sure
Miscanthus exist there we just haven't
collected it all right so we've done
some genome-wide Association and genomic
selection nothing to our shattering here
we had we had a lot of different traits
that aren't all shown here so we did
identify a pretty large number of snips
just across all of those traits and we
have a couple that's probably showing up
really tiny but a one for yield and one
for compressed circumference so we're
actually right next to QTL Peaks that
have been found in a mapping population
so that's somewhat promising and after
controlling for population structure we
have moderate genomic prediction
accuracies in this population and if we
combined all of our traits together to
make a yield index that improved our
prediction accuracy a bit
all right so Miscanthus sacra force is
the other species that were interested
in so this is the tetraploid parent of
giganteus and it exists in both diploid
and tetraploid forms so this is much
more of a spreading species you find it
growing along riverbanks in Asia and
there are a couple ornamental varieties
that you can purchase in the US but
they're less popular because this will
spread and take over your garden all
right so here's Eric back in 2012 in a
collection expedition to Russia so I
mentioned that some of these are winter
hardy up to zone 3 and in Russia so
here's a big field of a scant this Sacre
for us up there right and we also we
have field trials going those are
wrapping up so I don't really have
results to present yet but here's our
subtropical location and you can also
see there's some very tall sacré flores
in the background there all right so we
also you know ran rad seek on this and
did population structure to understand
the origins of these populations and
what they were right and so we have
three diploid populations this
northeastern one that's very widespread
sort of a North China diploid population
and then this Yangtze population which
is the subspecies uteri oh right Arius
so sometimes that's considered as its
own species but we found that it seems
to be this sort of bottleneck offshoot
from the north china population now but
this is an extremely high yielding
subpopulation of Miscanthus and we also
had three tetraploid populations so one
that was mainland Asia and then two in
Japan interestingly we found a couple of
tetraploid ZUP in Russia but there's you
know there's this whole region in
between where we didn't have any so
those might be some sort of relic or
perhaps the result of an anthropogenic
introduction although they do have some
genetic similarity to the diploid it's
nearby
one exciting thing we learned is that
the Japanese and mainland Asia a
tetraploid 's have different origins so
the the first split of these populations
from each other this is based on the
nuclear markers it's Japan versus
mainland which means that the Japan
polyploid ization has to be a different
different event from the mainland
polyploid ization event and we also
found that when we look at looked at
plastid markers we see the same thing
where the Asian tetraploid group in with
Asian dip Lloyd's
another really exciting and kind of
perplexing thing we found is that
somehow the tetraploid II is
facilitating introgression from the
other species even though they are
different floyd ii levels so we did find
diploid first-generation hybrids as i
mentioned some of those are
fantastically high yielding we have them
that we found both in korea and china
but we don't see them back crossing to
either species and we know that they're
fertile from our own experiments we've
been able to make f2 populations and
these sorts of things but in the wild we
just don't find those introgression but
in the tetraploid z-- we do find
tetraploid first-generation hybrids and
we see these a lot when we make crosses
to between diploid census in tetraploid
Sacre forests so something is sort of
selecting for non reduced gametes in in
census or something like that but
interestingly in the tetraploid z-- we
get all of this back crossing that
happens in nature so maybe this has
something to do with a dominance and
epistasis and the wheel dosage I think
this would be you know a very exciting
project to pursue in the future but
right now we don't have an answer for
why this is happening all right
we've also
able to compare the genetic diversity of
these and based on their population
structure estimate where they were
during the last glacial maximum so we
think that sacra Flores based on its
center of diversity was spread over a
much wider area so oh this you know at
this point this was a land mass right so
sacra Flores seems centered around here
since this was confined to this little
strip also based on what we know about
the vegetation history there and we see
that in the markers where we're using
the same marker system we got many more
markers with sacra Flores we got more
plastic tablet types of sacra forests
and the sign ANSYS populations are more
diverged from each other suggesting a
smaller effective population size you
know and and bigger bottleneck events as
it's spread out through Asia alright so
I mentioned that we have tetraploid
sacra Flores and we're getting going
with doing genome-wide Association for
that but we need a way to estimate
allele dosage from the genotyping by
sequencing data in those tetraploid x'
right and that is something that you
would expect to you know improve the G
wasps over just calling it as a sorry
Isaiah
naive diploid model right because this
is a linear regression and if you're
looking for additive effects you want to
estimate that allele dosage accurately
right so having it categorised stip
lloyd's versus tetraploid x' in this
case this tetraploid one did worse
because you know with the tetrapods we
if we're trying to really categorize it
as one genotype or the other we can do
so with less confidence so more of them
ended up being imputed but here are a
couple methods that I'm going to get
into where we can actually treat the
genotype as a continuous variable and
that estimates allele dosage and
incorporates our uncertainty and we can
still do linear regression with that for
G us
right so you know allele dosage is a big
issue in general with with polyploid
genotyping as well as allelic dropout
and if you want to you know be certain
that's not going to happen and that you
have various high certainty genotyping
you're going to have to spend quite a
lot of money sequencing at very high
depths which you might not want to do
and so even when you think okay it
should follow these nice ratios there
are technical issues that might bias it
towards one allele or the other so this
data can be pretty messy so with you
know the data that we can afford what's
the best genotype estimates we can do so
Bayesian genotype calling is a way to
deal with this so with as with no
Bayesian probability in general you have
a likelihood so the likelihood of the
data given the hypothesis so in this
case the hypothesis is this genotype is
a a a B my data is I have seven raids of
a and four weeds of B so what's the
probability that this genotype would
produce that redistribution you have a
prior which is how often am I generally
expecting to find a a a B in the
population and so you can do that using
allele frequencies and some other
population parameters all right I think
I will sit down at this point all right
and so you can put those together to get
a posterior probability saying okay if I
if I know that this is my read depth
what's the probability that that's the
true genotype right so in practicality
and you know and and what what this
actually amounts to is that when you
have very high depth the posterior
probabilities are driven by the
likelihoods so this is just diploid
examples for the sake of space but right
if I had you know a hundred reads and
they were all from one allele I'm gonna
say I'm pretty sure that's a homozygote
and so there's going to be a very low
likelihood on the other two genotypes
and so then it doesn't matter what
what the priors were so much so the
likelihood as here on the the height of
these rectangles the priors is the width
and then the posterior probability is
the area right and as read depth gets
lower we become less and less certain
about the genotypes based on read depth
alone and so then they're driven more by
the prior probabilities in terms of what
that genotype estimate is and one way
this plays out is that say you have a
rare allele in your population and you
have an individual that say has like
three reads and there of that allele and
no reads of a common allele so if you
went on likelihoods alone it would look
like a homozygote because that's the
most likely genotype but if you have
your priors you say well I'm not
expecting very many homozygotes of that
genotype so actually the most probable
genotype is the heterozygote and the
nice thing about this too is that if you
have informative Friar's this is
basically you're doing your genotyping
and your imputation at the same time
because if read depth is zero all of the
likelihoods are one and then the
posterior probability equals the prior
so we also get continuous you know types
out of this which are you know the so
these are posterior main genotypes
basically you multiply the allele copy
number each possible allele copy number
by the probability of that allele copy
number and then sum them together and so
this is a case where we're not really
sure if we have one or two copies and
there's even some probability of having
three copies so we have this sort of
average copy number across those and so
that gives you a continuous genotype
that you can still use for regression
against your phenotype all right so
there are a few pieces of software that
have all come out in the past couple of
years that will do this on eBay G is the
first one and that's based on
hardy-weinberg equilibrium with some op
for inbreeding or a low polyploid
there's an r package called up dog which
is a little better at modeling technical
issues that come up with library
preparation but it takes a while to
process and poly rod is mine and being
the more of a biologist whereas up dog
was made more by a statistician I'm
thinking about population structure and
linkage disequilibrium and how those
influence the priors and that means that
we're also not treating each marker in
isolation but the priors for one marker
are influenced by the genotypes at other
markers so that means that your high
depth markers are going to sort of help
pull up your load of markers in quality
and this is a case I might sort of
glossed through this because I know I'm
more limited for time that I thought I
would be of a population structure
influencing the priors so this is a PCA
of population structure and you can see
how the prior probabilities are varying
firm for this one particular marker or
varying across the population structure
so that means that that we're not using
the same priors over here that we are
over here and so each each individual
has its own prior for that genotype
based on who it's related to you know
what population it came from great and
this this is also a demonstration that
Polly red can improve phenotyping
accuracy with respect to some other
methods so gatk does a very naively
which has a even prior for everything
and it doesn't really model a low
polyploidy so this is a simulated allo
polyploid so Polly red is much better
than she 80k baby to make a long story
short being above the the solid line
here means that Polly red performed
better than this method great an up dog
and EBT or a bit better but in this case
Polly and still outperformed them and
then this is showing that basically you
can use polygraph for imputation at the
same time and that having population
structure and linkage disequilibrium are
useful for that imputation alright so
this is on our package available on cran
and github it can import in a variety of
formats it can work on both natural
populations and napping populations auto
and allele polyploids and I have a PhD
student who is right now working on a
study to to demonstrate that with Phase
II and genotype calling you're
increasing air power for chivas
hopefully it'll also show that poly rad
is the best but I'm okay if it shows
that as long as it shows the Bayesian
methods are better than my eat methods
alright so yeah we're last a few minutes
of my talk I'm going to talk ten minutes
okay I'm going to talk about a new
method that I'm working on for basically
correcting genome alignments so I've
been referring to Miscanthus is diploid
and tetraploid but even the diploid ZAR
actually an ancient allo tetraploid so
for each ancestral grass chromosome
there are two chromosomes in this campus
so that not only meant that it took us a
very long time to get a reference genome
but it means that we have a lot of
uncertainty in our alignments to that
reference genome and we can see some
evidence when we look at our sequence
read depths that these aren't really
Mendeley in low science so we probably
have some misaligned sequence tags all
right and so in part that's because if
you have a line or like bowtie or bwa
that was originally designed with the
human genome in mind and if you're
having it returned just the best
alignment you know the best alignment a
might not be the correct alignment and B
if it has two equally good alignments
it's taking what one at random and if I
know I have you know two paralogs I
really don't want to just pick one at
random right and so from pipelines for
variant calling like gatk in stacks
they're aligning every read so a set of
reads
that all belong to the same tag might be
aligned to a mix of different locations
or we've used tassel GPS a lot which
Alliance each tag once and then if
that's wrong then the whole data set is
wrong right
so observed heterozygosity is a really
good way to identify these collapse pair
logs but there are some issues
especially because there's a lot of
missing data and under sampling and
genotyping by sequencing so we might not
even sample both pair logs to see for
sure that that is looking heterozygous
when it shouldn't right and there are
other technical issues like messiness
that can make a homozygote look
heterozygous and of course I'm working
with an out crossing species so it's not
as easy a case with an inbred species
where it's like oh whoa nothing should
be heterozygous so if this is
heterozygous I'm automatically alright
so those are some limitations to using
hetero zygosity to identify these you
know virologist low sigh that were
combined into one and also because the
Bayesian genotype calling can be kind of
computationally intensive it would be
nice if we could filter before doing
that rather than after all right so
instead of using observed hetero
zygosity I've come up with this
statistic right now I'm calling it a
chin so this is sort of related to
observe and expect a hetero zygosity but
it's something that you measure in one
individual by one locus at a time and
you look at for that locus across all of
the tags and all of the read depth
you're getting in those tags what would
be the probability that if you sampled
two tags they would be different from
each other right so that doesn't require
you to call the genotype first it allows
for multiple alleles rather than being
forced to use like a by allelic snip so
it's using that that information like it
for the whole GBS tag and this will work
for for any ploidy
all right and so if I take that H end
and divide it by the expected hetero
zygosity um there is an expected value
and I'll talk a little bit about where
this comes from where it should be the
ploidy minus one divided by the floyd e
divided by or multiplied by one minus
the inbreeding coefficient so what I did
here was I took a bunch of sequencing
data from Miscanthus and I lined it both
to miss skipping the Miscanthus
reference which has both copies and to
sorghum where by landing it's a sorghum
I'm deliberately merging two per oolagah
slow site into one low size so i'm
deliberately making low say that are not
going to behave in a Mendelian way and
so if I take H end and H e H end over h
e for each locus and look at the
distribution of that with those two
alignments and sort of most of them are
much have a much higher value than what
I'm expecting to get
whereas Miscanthus they're right about
where I expect they're probably you know
the peak is just a little bit below
probably due to population structure but
I can see even when with Miscanthus I
have some of these that are higher than
expected which is probably those are the
ones that align to the wrong homeo log
and Miscanthus all right and so the
reason why this works out so H E is the
probability that in the whole population
if you sample two different alleles
they're going you know two alleles
they're going to be different from each
other
this point minus one over the poi D is
that if within one individual if you
sampled two chromosomes with replacement
that's the probability that there'll be
different chromosomes so that's like one
half in a diploid it's three quarters in
a tetraploid one minus F is the
probability that a pair of alleles in an
individual will not be identical by
descent so when these all are multiplied
together then you're getting the
probability that if you sample two
sequencing reads from that individual
that those different alleles are going
to be you know those two alleles are
going to be different from each other by
state
and what I haven't had add it in is that
these are would you scale it a little
bit by read depth to correct for just
the sample size of how many reads you
have in that that individual all right
so you do need a large population in
order to do this so this isn't going to
save an rna-seq experiment or something
like that but it's good for for variant
calling in big populations it is only
good up to a certain read depth like I
found if my median read depth is five or
lower there's not really much point to
doing this statistic but the the higher
the read depth the less variance you're
going to get in the estimate right and
you might also need to know or you do
need to know poi D and inbreeding but
you can take a good guess at those just
looking at the initial distribution of
that if you had to and I'm still
thinking about how to do it for mapping
populations I'm sure it shouldn't be
that too complicated I just need to
think on the math for that alright so
this is useful not only for filter you
can say okay the value is too high I'm
throwing out that locus but we could use
this statistic for actually correcting
alignments so if Allah oh if we allow
for multiple alignments and we see okay
there are multiple places this tag could
go then we can kind of rearrange the
sequence tags across alignment locations
to try to optimize this statistic so
both of these have implementation that's
mostly done that will be released with
poly rod
alright okay I'm actually well I'm on
time it was fifty minutes last night
okay so I yeah me and this is a kind of
a complicated flowchart but this is my
algorithm for rearranging those tags to
try to optimize alignment so I actually
start with the first couple of steps of
castle GPS because it's very efficient
for finding all of the unique sequence
tags in the GPS data set and then
tallying up the read depth of each of
those tags in every individual and like
castle and doing been doing an alignment
but I'm allowing multiple alignments to
be reported if I have more alignments
than the number of sub genomes that I'm
expecting I throw the marker out but if
you know if I have an a low tetraploid
and I have two alignments then I'm going
to keep that and say okay probably this
this belongs to one of those two and
then I group up the tags based on the
unordered set of alignment so it doesn't
matter which alignment was better just
that the set of tags all aligned to the
same two places and so initially I
assign and I am using the term iso locus
here to be basically mean one per olga's
locus or the other so based on you know
where did it align best that's the
initial assignment and then I check okay
does this exceed my expectation for my
agent over a Qi statistic if it doesn't
then that's good I'm going to keep that
set of alignments if it does that I'm
going to try swapping some of the tags
around so first they use negative read F
correlations which I don't have time to
explain why that works but a few years
ago I published something and
microsatellites on on how you can see if
two alleles belong to the same locus or
not based on these correlations and so
if two alleles are negatively correlated
I make sure that they both go to the
same alignment location and then again I
okay did that fix my problem and if it
doesn't then I perform a type of search
algorithm called a taboo search where I
look okay for this solution of groups of
tags what are all of the neighboring
solutions and are any of them better
right and eventually if I if I just
can't
you'll get that value below an
acceptable cutoff and I'm going to throw
away the marker but in most cases this
algorithm has worked for for fixing that
value so here I have like the starting H
end over AG on the x-axis and the final
agent HEU on the y-axis after running
this algorithm so a lot of them started
quite a bit above the expectation but if
I just swapped one or two tags I was
able to get it to at or below the
expected Bell expected value and that
worked out both in diploid x' and
tetraploid so something that was
tetraploid on top of being a low
tetraploid all right and so of course in
this this is all empirical data so I
don't know if I got it right I just know
the statistic looks better so my
master's student meant Whitney Mays is
working on simulating some sequence tags
from an owl polyploid genome and
simulating the read depth I'm not seeing
if this algorithm is finding the right
answers or not all right so thank you
very much for the invitation and I'll
take any questions does it ever make a
lot of seed or are we just substituting
oh so much I mean Miscanthus oh yeah
yes so it is asking about the harvest
index for Miscanthus and it's the UM if
the hybrids produce a lot of seed or not
so Miscanthus in general its it produces
lots of very tiny seeds I don't know if
we've looked at seed production for the
hybrids I mean we're talking about eel
yield for for dry biomass overall I mean
they've been they tend to be fertile
enough that we get enough seed that we
can make you know make an f2 from them I
think they're well actually I don't know
if they have reduced fertility but I
know in some cases we we have observed
that the self-incompatibility starts to
break down a little bit so starts asking
about why would Bayesian um genotype
calling be better in a poly play then
than normal do traditional genotype
calling I mean I think that it it can be
better in a polyploid or a diploid but
the I mean the the real place where it's
better is where you just have too few
reeds to have high confidence in the
genotype based on read-depth
alone and so that's where having a prior
probability from the population is going
to improve the accuracy a lot and
because you know and in diploid that's
not especially in an inbred deploy but
even in an out in a crossing diploid
it's not too hard to get enough depth
that you can be fairly sure
jeanna tights but that the depth needed
for high confidence goes up very very
fast as you increase the ploidy to the
point where it's it's just not worth the
money to get enough sequencing deaths to
be sure about the genotype so then then
having having something that's going to
kind of coax the calls in the right
direction I think is then helpful yeah
so the question was how did we identify
the the Palais DS in the sacra Forest
collection we did do
flow cytometry on pretty much everything
you know I think there was a small
minority of genotypes where we didn't
have material for flow cytometry
especially where we we didn't have any
one location where everything was alive
so that was a limitation but because we
had flow cytometry on almost everything
we were able to classify the rest based
on their apparent hetero zygosity and
based on which genetic group they were
in
um diploid versus oh yeah repeat the
question yeah so what else a Tama tree
could we have done this so we if I
plotted like a overall missing data rate
versus overall heterozygosity that it
was it was pretty easy to tell the
diploid apart versus the triploids and
tetraploid x' but distinguishing the
triploids of tetraploid from each other
was I don't think we would have been
able to confidently do that especially
because there was so much hybridization
that was a little bit of a confounding
factor too because that's going to give
it you can see the data structure you
created so the question is what the have
I been working with the agent on shotgun
sequencing data instead of GPS data well
I haven't I haven't quite primarily
because I don't have any shotgun
sequencing like data sets from our lab
to work with right and then then you
kind of have to I guess decide you know
are are you going to like find a certain
haplotype level at which you're working
with the data are you going to try to
work with it as by allelic snip markers
so yeah I haven't gotten into that but
that is certainly be an interesting
application you might have to repeat
okay so will the statistic all right
look western is relation over h he
worked for auto polyploids
I mean so so part with the I mean the
goal that I was showing was determining
which sub genome it it it goes to and in
Auto polyploid you you only have you
know one one genome but it might still
be useful for estimating the ploidy
right because the expectation is that if
you divide it by it expected hetero
zygosity it's going to be you know one
half for a diploid or three quarters for
a tetraploid and so on so it might be
useful for distinguishing employees in a
case where you've got sequencing data
but you're not able to do flow cytometry
yes I think that yes so the question
question is if you have you know gene
duplications on top of the allo
polyploidy duplication is that going to
complicate this method and yes
especially if you're saying okay I'm
just trying to sort it into two loci and
the reality is that there are four or
six then right you're not going to be
getting the right answer and then your
agent over HG estimates are probably
still going to be too high when they're
done so I mean right as I've written the
pipeline
right now that would probably just get
thrown out but you could hypothetically
say okay well I'm going to open it up to
looking for you know more and more low
sigh it's just how accurately is it
going to be able to do that is the
question I think this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu